>> WELCOME BACK TO THIS SPECIAL
EDITION OF "HANNITY: JUSTICE IN
AMERICA" WITH THE DEMOCRATS'
COLLUSION CONSPIRACY EXPOSED AS
A HOAX, IT LOOKS LIKE A NEW
ROUND OF PARTY INFIGHTING IS ON
THE HORIZON.
IT LOOKS LIKE AS NANCY PELOSI
AND STENY HOYER ARE SIGNALING
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT, THAT'S NOT
STOPPING RANKED FILE LAWMAKERS
FROM PUSHING THEIR OWN AGENERAL
AT A AND REFUSING TO FULLY
ACCEPT MUELLER'S NO CONCLUSION
FINDING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU ACCEPT THE CONCLUSION
THERE WAS NO CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY.
>> I ACCEPT THAT CONCLUSION FOR
NOW.
BUT THERE'S A NEED FOR
CONTINUING INVESTIGATION.
THERE ARE CLEARLY OFFENSES.
>> IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES?
>> THERE MAY BE, THERE MAY BE
CENSURABLE OFFENSES.
>> DO YOU ACCEPT THE CENTRAL
COUNSEL'S CONCLUSION ON THAT
POINT?
>> TO A DEGREE.
BUT, AGAIN, WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION.
>> I BELIEVE IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES HAVE BEEN COMMITTED AND
I BELIEVE IT'S WORTHWHILE TO PUT
IN HISTORY'S FILES WHAT THIS MAN
HAS DONE AND IMPEACH HIM.
THE BASE WANTS IMPEACHMENT, THEY
WANT IT BADLY.
>> THAT WAS MR. COHEN WHO I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF SERVING WITH IN
CONGRESS.
WOW.
AND IT GETS WORSE, BECAUSE 2020
CANDIDATE SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN IS JOINING THE
IMPEACHMENT CHORUS TWEETING THE
HOUSE SHOULD INITIATE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, END QUOTE.
ECHOING HER ARE CONGRESSWOMAN
RASHIDA TALIB ALL DESPITE THE
FINDINGS OF NO CRIMINAL
WRONGDOING BY THE PRESIDENT.
JOINING ME FOR REACTION IS SARAH
CARTER AND CONGRESSMAN MIKE
TURNER OF OHIO AND ANDY BIGGS OF
ARIZONA.
TO THE THREE OF YOU, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US HERE.
I WANT TO START WITH MIKE
TURNER, YOU'RE IN OHIO BUT
YOU'RE ALSO ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
THEY'RE SINGING THE TUNE OF
IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> THIS IS PART OF THE PROCESS
OF TRYING TO DELEGITIMIZE A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
THEY DID IT WITH GEORGE BUSH'S
ELECTION WHERE THEY ALLEGED THEY
COLLUDED WITH HIS BROTHER
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
THEY TOOK THAT TO THE SUPREME
COURT.
THEN NOW WITH TRUMP, THEY SAID
THEY STOLE THE ELECTION AND
HILLARY CLINTON FUNDED MATERIAL
TO GET SURVEILLANCE OVER THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IN THE HEARTLAND
RIGHT HERE IN DAY TON, OHIO THE
THE HEADLINE THAT HIT
EVERYBODY'S DOORSTEP TODAY WAS
NO COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
THAT'S GOT A BIG IMPACT.
THE PRESIDENTIAL TWEET, THAT'S
THE HEADLINE.
IT WILL MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ADAM SHIFT GOING
AROUND SAYING THERE IS
COLLUSION.
NOW THEY'RE SEEING THEIR SHIFT.
NOW THEY WANT TO GO FROM
COLLUSION TO SAYING THEY WANT TO
GO AFTER THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
OF HIS OPPOSITION FOR THEIR
EFFORTS TO PURSUE HIM FOR CRIMES
HE DIDN'T COMMIT.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE WILL BUY
IT.
THEY'LL TAKE THE FOUR WORDS WITH
NO COLLUSION WITH RUSSIANS TO BE
THE END OF IT.
>> SARAH, I WANT TO GET YOUR
IMPACT ON THIS.
SENATOR WARREN, SHE WANTS TO
HAVE IMPEACHMENT.
HOW WILL IT GO?
>> I DON'T THINK IT WILL GO
WELL.
IT WILL BACKFIRE.
IT WILL BACKFIRE ON THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IS SICK AND
TIRE OF THIS.
THEY KNOW NOW BASED ON THIS
REPORT, NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
NOW YOU'RE HEARING IN YOUR OWN
REPORT THAT EVEN DODD McGANN,
HIS STORY CHANGED MULTIPLE
TIMES, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
LAWYER AND THERE WAS A SECTION
IN THE REPORT THAT SPECIFICALLY
STATED THAT HIS STORY WAS
CONFUSING.
SO, AS FAR AS THE OBSTRUCTION IS
CONCERNED, THERE'S NO
OBSTRUCTION THERE.
THIS IS COMING FROM -- IT'S --
YOU KNOW, FROM ELIZABETH WARREN
WHO WAS BASICALLY CALLED OUT FOR
LYING ON HER CARD AND CALLING
HERSELF AN AMERICAN INDIAN.
AND WE KNOW THAT SHE'S NOT.
THIS IS GOING TO BACKFIRE ON
HER.
THIS IS GOING TO BACKFIRE ON THE
DEMOCRATS.
ADAM SHIFT IS ANOTHER ONE THAT'S
BEEN VERY MUCH PUSHING THIS
CONCLUSION ILLUSION NARRATIVE
CONSISTENTLY AT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
IS GOING TO GET TIRED OF THAT.
AND I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING ELSE, THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING I BELIEVE JASON
IS THAT COMING UP WHEN THE
INVESTIGATION START ON THE PART
OF WILLIAM BARR AND WHEN THE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE REVEALED THAT
MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS CONDUCTING
OVER THE PAST YEAR, IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BACKFIRE ON THEM.
>> ANDY BIGGS, YOU'RE A
CONGRESSMAN ON THE EAST SIDE OF
THE PHOENIX VALLEY THERE IN
MESA, ARIZONA, AN IMPORTANT
STATE IN THE 2020 POLITICS.
THE DEMOCRATS YOU SERVE IN THE
HOUSE, DO THEY REALLY LOVE MIKE
PENCE THAT MUCH?
DO THEY WANT TO BE THE
PRESIDENT?
OR ARE ON THIS CRAZY TRAIN TO
WHO KNOWS WHEREWITHAL OF THIS
IMPEACHMENT TALK.
>> THEY'RE ON THE CRAZY TRAIN.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
THAT ARE SKITTISH AND WISELY SO.
THEY DON'T WANT AN IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS.
IT WILL HURT THEM.
THE 40 DISTRICTS WE CALL SWING
DISTRICTS THAT SUPPORT TRUMP
THAT MAY BE A DEMOCRAT PICKED UP
THE LAST TERM ELECTION.
BUT NADLER SUBPOENAING THESE
DOCUMENTS AND HE'S GOING
FORWARD, I THINK THEY'RE DOING A
MARKET TEST TO SEE IF THEY'RE
ABLE TO KEEP THE MIDDLE THAT
THEY'RE HOPING TO GET BY IF THEY
GO TO A FULL IMPEACHMENT.
THEY WANT TO DO A FULL
IMPEACHMENT.
THEY THINK THE BASE IS GINNED UP
ENOUGH TO DO IT.
BUT THERE ARE WISE HEADS OR
POLITICALLY MINDED HEADS WHEN
PELOSI OR STENNY HOYER IS
SAYING, HEY, THIS IS GOING TO
HURT US IF WE DO IT.
YOU KNOW NADLER, YOU KNOW SHIFT,
THEY WANT TO GO FORWARD AND TEST
IT TO SEE IF WE CAN STAY IN
THERE.
>> YOU HAD MORE THAN 60
DEMOCRATS SIGN UP FOR
IMPEACHMENT BEFORE IT CUTS
THROUGH THE REPORT.
CONGRESSMAN TURNER, YOU SERVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
YOU SEE DAY IN AND DAY OUT
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
HOW DOES HE HAVE ANY
CREDIBILITY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW HE HAS
SECURITY CLEARANCE AND WHY HE'S
ON THE COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT.
>> WELL, IT IS VERY TROUBLING,
CERTAINLY ALL OF THE REPUBLICANS
ON THE COMMITTEE CALLED FOR HIS
REMOVAL AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE, NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THE MISSTATEMENTS THAT HE'S MADE
WHERE HE'S COME OUT AND HE SAID
HE SAW EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
WHERE THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
NOW THE MUELLER REPORT, WITHOUT
QUESTION, SETTLES THAT ISSUE.
BUT THE ISSUE IS HE IS USING THE
COMMITTEE SOLELY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF SUING PRESIDENT
TRUMP WITH HIS VENDETTA AGAINST
HIM.
THE ADVERSARIES ARE NORTH KOREA,
CHINA, RUSSIA, AND IRAN.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE WAY
THEY'RE IMPACTING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AS LONG AS ADAM SHIFT BELIEVES
THE GREATEST THREAT TO THIS
COUNTRY IS DONALD TRUMP, OUR
ADVERSARIES IS GETTING A PASS
AND OUR COMMITTEE NEEDS TO GET
BACK TO WORK.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
THERE'S A HUGE OPPORTUNITY COST
BY NOT FOCUSING ON OTHER TRUE
THREATS TO THIS NATION.
I GOT 30 SECONDS LEFT.
SARA CARTER, WHERE DOES THIS GO
NEXT?
>> WE KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING.
IT'S GOING TO DEEP
INVESTIGATIONS TO THE GENESIS OF
THE ORIGINATION OF THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
INDICTMENTS.
I BELIEVE PEOPLE WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK, JASON,
THAT ANY TYPE OF IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS OR HEARINGS OF THAT
NATURE ARE JUST GOING TO
BACKFIRE ON THE DEMOCRATS.
>> CONGRESSMAN BIGGS, LAST WORD.
DO WE ACTUALLY SEE PEOPLE IN
HANDCUFFS HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE GENESIS AND THE ABUSING THE
FISA COURT SYSTEM?
>> WE'D BETTER.
BECAUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DEMAND THAT.
AND I -- IF WE DON'T, IT'S JUST